مشاهدينا اهلا بكم انا ميسون عزام احييكم
وهذه التغطيه مستمره للاوضاع في السودان
تبادل الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
الاتهامات حول استهداف المدنيين وفي وقت
تستمر فيه عمليات الاجلاء التي تنفذها
الدول الغربيه وايضا العربيه
لدبلوماسيين وراعاياها تتزايد عمليات نزوح
السودانيين هربا من الاقتتال الدائر
[موسيقى]
وبينما تستمر عمليات الاجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب من السودان مع استمرار المواجهات
قال اللواء بحري ركن صلاح بابكر عمر قائد
الفرقه 101 مشاه في البحريه السودانيه
للعربيه قال ان هناك تسهيلات لاجراءات
دخول سفن اجراء الرعايه الاجانب دعونا
نتابع حاولنا نسهل كل الاجراءات المتعلقه
بالمواني بدخول السفن
ورباطه وايضا بوصول الرعايه هنا وتجميعهم
وضيافتهم وما الى ذلك من من اجراءات حقيقه
كانت عمليات الاجلاء يعني مشهد بالطريقه
سلسه جدا
سهلنا كل الاجراءات حتى الاجراءات الرسميه
للجوازات
والجمارك كانت في مكان استقبال هذه
الجاليات الان احنا بصدد عندنا الان بتحمل
ثلاثه سفن اللي هي سفن من المملكه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعندنا سفينه هنديه
وعندنا سفينه كوريه جنوبيه وفي انتظار عدد
اخر من السفن حقيقه
ومن جانبه قال مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل بان الكتله
الاوروبيه لن تسمح بانفجار الوضع في
السودان اضاف على هامش اجتماع لوزراء
خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي اضافه ان عمليه
اجلاء موظفي الاتحاد قد نجحت دعونا نتابعه
لقد كانت عمليه معقده لكنها ناجحه موظف
الاتحاد الاوروبي 21 شخصا موجودون بالفعل
في اوروبا والعديد من مواطني الاتحاد
الاوروبي خارج السودان بالفعل لا استطيع
ان اعطيك الرقم الملموسه لكن تقريبا اكثر
من الف شخص اود ان اشكر فرنسا على
مساهمتها علينا ان نواصل الضغط من اجل
تسويه سياسيه لا يمكننا ان نتحمل ان ينهار
السودان لانه سيرسل موجات صدمه في جميع
انحاء افريقيا
ردا على سؤال العربيه ان المجتمع الدولي
يضغط على المكونين العسكريين في السودان
ويقوم ببذل جهود مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب
للوصول الى تسويه سياسيه
المجتمع الدولي يضغط على الطرفين ويقوم
ببذل جهود مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب وبلوغ
تسويه سياسيه لقد كنت اتحدث مع جميع
الجيران وجميع الاصدقاء حتى مع وجود
الجنرلين اللذين يقودان القوات رساله
المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب واسكات
المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث عن الحل
السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري لهذه الحرب
وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال اخراج مواطنينا
لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك تراه انت
تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج مواطنون
ومن المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل
كدبلوماسي
لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو اخراجهم
على كل لمتابعه عمليات الاجلاء المستمره
معنا من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في
جده سلطان السلمي مراسل العربيه اهلا بك
سلطان الجديد لديك تفضل
اهلا بك نتحدث انه من المتوقع خلال
الساعتين القادمه ان تصل الطائره الكوريه
الخاصه بعمليات الاجلاء من مطار بورت
سودان الى مطار قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه بجده هنا وعلى متنها 29 موظف
دبلوماسي وبمقدمتهم السفير الكوري هناك
هناك في الخرطوم جميع الرعايه التي سوف
يتم اجلاؤهم خلال الساعات القادمه هم من
الجنسيه الكوريه بمقدمتهم كما ذكرنا قبل
قليل السفير الكوري في العاصمه الخرطوم اذ
تم نقلهم برا من العاصمه الخرطوم الى
بورسودان ومن ثم متوقع خلال الساعتين
القادمه ان تصل الى مطار او الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده كما يظهر
امامكم هذه الطائره العسكريه الكوريه لانه
هي الخاصه بعمليه نقلهم من القاعده الملك
عبد الله الجويه بالقطاع الغربي في جده
هنا الى
في كوريا خلال بعد وصول الطائره الاجلال
الذي متوقع الوصول خلال الساعتين القادمه
لذلك هذه الطائره هي مخصصه لنقلهم من جده
الى كوريا نتحدث عن التسويق كبير بين
الحكومه السعوديه والحكومه مباشره ام في
هناك تجهيزات اخرى نتحدث
ساعه واحده فقط هنالك المديريه العامه
للجوازات والجمارك سوف يقومون بانهاء كافه
الاجراءات الخاصه بالرعايه الكوريين في
حين وصولهم الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه سوف يتم انهاء كافه الاجراءات
الخاصه بهم ومن ثم سوف يستقلون هذه
الطائره
ذها الى سيول في كوريا نتحدث انه هنالك
تنسيق امني كبير بين الحكومه السعوديه
والحكومه الكوريه
للتاكيد والتنسيق العمليه هذه الاجلاء
لوصولها الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
نتحدث انه هذه العمليه هي العمليه الاخلاب
او الاجلاء الجويه الاولى التي سوف تصل
الى السعوديه بعد ان كان هنالك عمليات
اجلاء بحريه تمت خلال اليومين الماضيه اذا
تحدث عن وصول 157 شخص من ضمنهم 91 سعودي
وسته وستين شخص غير سعود يتحدث على جنسيات
خليجيه وعربيه وكذلك من دول اوروبيه هذه
الطائره التي سوف تقل الرعايه الكوريين
عددهم 29 شخص هم جميعهم د او موظفيه
السفاره الكوريه في الخرطوم سوف يصل على
متنها كذلك السفير الكوري هنالك في
الخرطوم سوف يتم استقباله من قبل السفير
الكوري في السعوديه وعدد من القيادات
الامنيه هنا في قاعه الملك عبد الله
الجويه بجده لانهاء الكافه الاجراءات
المتعلقه بهم لاستقلال هذه الطائره
العسكريه الضخمه بالنسبه
كبير
وبهذا الاطار نحن نتحدث عن اكثر من جنسيه
الجانب الكوري مباشره بعد ساعه من وصولهم
سيعودون الى وطنهم الام ماذا عن بقيه
الجنسيات التي وصلت اصلا طبيعه التنسيق
الذي تم وهل بالفعل عادوا او عاد البعض
منهم الى بلدانهم
نؤكد انه هذه العمليه الخلاء الجوي
العمليه الاولى التي سوف تصل الى مدينه
جده كخلاء جوي من بورس من مطار برج سودان
وصولا الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
هنا في جده فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء
البحري التي تمت خلال يومين الماضيه اذا
تحدثنا عن المواطنين دوله الكويت تم سفرهم
الى الكويت في نفس
الباقي الجنسيات ولكن مضطره ان انتقل الى
جلسه في مجلس الامن و يتحدث هناك عن
السودان نستمع جهودنا مع الاطراف كفى وذلك
من اجل وقف هذا الاقتتال في اقرب الاجال
واذا نعمل مع منظمات الانسانيه في الميدان
فاننا نعيد تشكيل وجودنا في السودان بما
يمكننا من مواصله تقديم الدعم للشعب
السوداني ولاكون واضحا الامم الامم
المتحده لن تغادر السودان
فالتزامنا ايذاء الشعب السوداني وذلك
تلبيه لرغبتهم من اجل المستقبل امن ومبهر
ونحن نقف الى جانبهم في هذه الاوقات
العصيبه ولقد اصدرت تعليماتي
اللي مختلفه العاملين بالامم المتحده خارج
السودان
وداخله واسرهم وادعو كل الاطراف المعنيه
وكذلك كل اعضاء مجلس الامن بضروره ممارسه
نفوذهم على الطرفين من اجل العوده الى
النظام علينا
من حافه الهاويه سيدي الرئيس شكرا جزيلا
لدعوتك لعقد مجلس الامن اليوم حول هذه
المساله جد المهمه الا وهي تعدديه الاطراف
الفاعله التعاون
التعاون المتعدد الاطراف هو القلب النابض
للامم المتحده وانشاء الامم المتحده في
عام 1945 مثل افضل محاوله انسانيه لمنع
تكرار ويلات الحربين العالميتين على مدار
78 عاما
تماسك نظام المتعدد الاطراف واطلع وحقق
نجاحات ملموسه ان الادوات
والاليات التي انشات بموجب
اذا مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذه
الكلمه للامين العام للامم المتحده
والمتعلقه بالسودان والوضع هناك على كل مع
استمرار المواجهات المسلحه تتزايد معها
عمليات النزوح في السودان التقارير تشير
الى دخول حوالي عشره الاف نازح سوداني الى
الاراضي الواقعه في جنوب السودان خلال
الايام الماضيه هربا من القتال الدائر
فيما عبر الحدود حوالي 6500 لاجئ سوداني
يوم السبت الماضي في وقت لا تزال اعداد
اللاجئين مرشحه للزياده مع استمرار
المواجهات
المدى الزمني لنزاع الدائره حاليا في
السودان غير واضح لكن اجلاء الدول
لدبلوماسيه وايضا لراعيها يؤشر لخطورته
وايضا طول امدح حيث تتواصل العمليات وجهود
اجلاء البعثات الدبلوماسيه ان كان العربيه
والاجنبيه والرعايه العرب والاجانب من
السودان مع استمرار المواجهات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
فمسارعه الدول الغربيه طبعا بمقدماتها
الولايات المتحده لاجلاء الدبلوماسيه
واغلاق السفاره مؤشر واقرار ضمن ربما بان
الحرب الدائره قد لا تتوقف قريبا قرار
الدول بني وفق مراقبين على استبعاد تسويه
عبر المفاوضات او حسم احد الطرفين المعركه
لمصلحته سريعا كما ان الخطوه الامريكيه
بارسال فريق استجابه للكوارث الى المنطقه
لتنسيق الاستجابه الانسانيه للمحتاجين
داخل وايضا خارج السودان يعني غياب اي
مساعد جديه او خطه ملموسه لوقف القتال في
السودان ليبقى السيناريو الاكثر ترجيحا هو
استمرار المعارك حينها كل طرف من اطراف
النزاع سيبحث عن داعمين له للصمود في
المعركه لاطول فتره ممكنه وبالتالي تعميق
الازمه المد بان هدرات عده فشلت وفرا
الالاف من السودانيين بحثا عن الامان ان
كان الى تشاد المجاوره الفقيره ففي
الخرطوم حاليا لا ماء لا كهرباء وايضا
الوصول الامن للطعام غير مكفول
الوصول بمواطنيهم الى بر الامان كان هدف
الدول التي يوجد لها رعايه في السودان
لاخراجهم عبر عمليات اجلاء عاجله عده
مسارات تمت لعمليات الاجلاء منها عبر
قاعده ولد سيدنا الجوي في ام درمان ونقلهم
الى بورت سودان ومنها جوا الى دولهم خط
اخر للاجلاء كان ايضا عبر بورسودان لكن
بحرا عبر سفن حربيه تنقلهم الى مدينه جده
على الضفه الاخرى من البحر الاحمر قبل نقل
المواطنين الى بلدانهم من مسارات اجلاء
ولمتابعه عمليات الاجلاء المستمره نعود
الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده
ومعنى من هناك سلطان السلمي مراسل العربيه
وطلعنا عن الوضع الان ويبدو ان الطائره
الحربيه التي تنقل
الدبلوماسيين الكوريين وعلى راسهم السفير
الكوري قد وصلت الان وحطت في مطار الملك
عبد الله الجوي في جده
سلطان
بالفعل
كما تشاهدون الان هي صور حصريه ومباشره
امامكم لوصول الطائره العسكريه الكوريه
الخاصه بعمليات الاجلاء الخاصه بالرعايه
الكوريين الدبلوماسيين وبمقدمتهم السفينه
الكوري في الخرطوم كما نشاهد هذه الطائره
العسكريه على رقم سيئه 130 وهي على متنها
29 موظف دبلوماسي في السفاره الكوريه في
الخرطومه بمقدمتهم كذلك السفير
الكوري في الخرطوم ايضا نتحدث انه تمت
عمليات الاسلام من مطار بورش سودان وايضا
على هذا الرقم سنتحدث على 77 شخص من
الرعايه الكوريين جميعهم من الرعايه
الكوريين وصلت هذه الطائره الان الى مطار
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه بجده سوف يتم
استقبالهم من قبل السفينه الكوري في
السعوديه وعدد من قيادات الامنيه هنا في
السعوديه كما نشاهد الان هذه الطائره وصلت
سوف يتم استقبالهم وانهاء كافه الاجراءات
السفر الخاصه بهم ومن ثم [__] الطائره
الاخرى وصولا فورا خلال ساعه من بعد الان
الى العاصمه الكوريه سي او نتحدث انه هذه
الرحله تمت بعد تنسيق امني كبير ما بين
الحكومه السعوديه والحكومه الكوريه اذا
اذا بدات الرحله من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وصولا الى بورسودان ومن ثم جو
الهادي تعتبر اول رحله اخلاء جوي تصل الى
السعوديه وتحديدا الى القاعده الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه بالقطاع الغربي هذه
الصوره حيه كما نشاهد امامكم السفير
السعودي السفير الكوري بالسعوديه وعدد من
قطاع قطاع او قيادات الامنيه متواجدين
لاستقبالهم نتحدث انه هذه الرعايه سوف
يصلون الان تنزلون من هذه الطائر العسكريه
التي تسمى 130 الان بانتظرون هناك
موطفي من وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه وعدد من
القطعات الامنيه كما نشاهد الان لاستقبال
اول عمليه اخلاء
جوي تتم من عبر مطار برج سودان وصولا الى
مدينه جده هنا في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه سلطان قبل قليل
بعمليه النزول كما نشاهد الان وذكرت قبل
قليل انه بقائهم في جده سيكون لمده ساعه
فقط
لتخليص الاجراءات الورقيه ومن ثم مباشره
وكنا قد شاهدنا قبل قليل صور الطائره التي
ستنقلهم الى بلدهم الام
[موسيقى]
قليل هي جاهزه لعمليه نقلهم بعد انهاء
كافه اجراءات السفر الخاصه بهم المتوقع
سوف يستغرق ذلك ساعه نظرا لوجود المديريه
العامه للجوازات وكافه القطاعات الامنيه
للتسهيل عمليه وصولهم وسفرهم الى سيول في
كوريا نتحدث له هنالك عدد كبير من
القطاعات الامنيه متواجده والحكوميه
لانهاء اجراءات سفرهم بعد الاطمئنان عليهم
والتاكد من سلامتهم وصحتهم نتحدث عن 29 من
لا اعلم ان كان لدينا تفاصيل حول من هم
على متن هذه الطائره ان كانت 29 دبلوماسي
ام من الدبلوماسيين مع عائلاتهم وان كان
هناك اطفال ونساء ايضا يتواجدون علامات
هذه الطائره
دبلوماسيين من الجاليه الكوريه في الخرطوم
وذلك بمقدمه السفير
معكم عمليات الاجلاس سوف يقومون بالنزول
من الطائره الان وسوف نشاهد من علامات كان
هنالك عائلات او حتى اطفال او غير ذلك
نتحدث كذلك انه هنالك تنسيق كبير بين
القطاعات الامنيه هنا وكذلك كافه القطاعات
وكذا من مندوبي السفاره الكوريه
لاستقبالهم الان في هذه اللحظات الان
ثواني محدوده سوف يتم استقبالهم بالحلوى
وبالورود حتى يتم استقبالهم نعم لحظات
محدوده الان كما نظره امامكم في هذه الصور
الحيه والمباشر سوف يتم استقبالهم بالحلوى
وبالورود لانها بعد ذلك كافه اجراءات
السفر الخاصه به ومن ثم استقلال الطائره
الاخرى وصولا الى سيئون نتحدث على من ساعه
الى ساعتين سوف يتم انهاء كافه اجراءات
بعد التاكد بسلامتهم وصحتهم
هذه اول طائره اخلاء جوي تصل الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده بعد ان كان
هنالك عمليات اخرى تمت عبر البحر وتحديد
عبر قوات البحريه السعوديه نتحدث على 157
الشخص تم نقلهم من قبل قوات البحريه
السعوديه نتحدث عن واحد واحد وتسعين
السعودي ومن ضمنهم 66 اجنبي نتحدث على
جنسيات مختلفه الدول من دول بلغاريا ومن
كندا وكذلك من الدول
طيب الصوره تتقطع وايضا الصوت يتقطع ولكن
لازمنا
سلطان تقطع الصوت عند ما وصلت الى الاعداد
فيما يتعلق بمن وصلوا بحرا والان نتحدث عن
اول رحله جويه تصل الى السعوديه الان
وبانتظار طبعا بالورد
وايضا الحلوى وصول الكوريين نتحدث عن 25
كوري او 29 على ما اذكر وايضا على راسهم
السفير الكوري في السودان وفي استقبالهم
السفير الكوري في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اضافه الى عدد من الشخصيات
الامنيه المتواجده الان طائره ايضا جاتمه
في المطار بانتظار ان تنقلهم بعد تخليص
الاجراءات الاداريه
والامنيه ان تنقلهم الى بلدهم الام
سلطان
نعم بالفعل الان لحظات محدوده جدا وسوف
نشاهد معكم وبرفقتكم نزول الرعايه الكوريه
القادمين من مطار السودان نتحدث الرحله
استغرقت الساعه ونصف من مطار بورت سوداني
الى وصولا الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه هنا بمدينه جده سوف نشاهد الان
معكم بعد لحظات بسيطه وصول الرعايه
ونزولهم الى القاعده بعد تاكل من صحتهم
وسلامتهم وانهاء كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه
بهم كامل وشاهد الى القطاعات امنيه كبيره
وكذلك ممثلين وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
وايضا وجود السفير الكوري في السعوديه
لاستقباله كما نشاهد الان هؤلاءهم اول
النازلين من هذه الطائره الكوريه كما
نشاهد الان من المعتقد انه هنالك كما
نشاهد الان السيدات
تم استقبالهم بالورده والحلوى والاعلام
السعوديه والكوريه وايضا يتم تقديم
المساعده لهم بشكل فوري ومباشر كما نشاهد
الان عددهم كما ذكرنا قبل قليل 29 شخص
جميعهم من الدبلوماسيين وكذلك بمقدمتهم
السفير الكوري في الخرطوم تم اجلائهم
جميعا بالتنسيق مع السعوديه والحكومه
الكوريه وصولي الى مطار القاعده للتاكد من
صحتهم وسلامتهم كما نشاهد الان بعائلاتهم
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل والاطفال نشاهد هذه
الفتاه والامتعه القليله جدا بمثل هذه
الحالات الدبلوماسيه الكامله بمثل هذه
الحالات عاده ما قل ودل اذا ما صح التعبير
الوضع نعم بالفعل بالفعل الوضع في خرطوم
كان فوضوي وصعب جدا وتعزم بشكل كبير خلال
حتى هذه القطه ايضا وحتى حيوانات تم
اجلائهم وصولا الى جده هنالك تفاصيل دقيقه
جدا تهتم بها الحكومه السعوديه في عمليات
الاجلاء بنقل كل ما يملكونه او يملكونه او
حتى متعلق بممتلكاتهم الشخصيه وايضا نتحدث
ايضا عن كافه العائلات سوف وصلت وتم اخلاء
جميع الجاليه الكوريه هنالك في الخرطوم
عبر هذه الطائره وهم جميع ممثلي البعثات
الدبلوماسيه وعائلاتهم
العربيه السعوديه سلطان نلاحظ بان معظمهم
يحملون الاعلام السعوديه طبعا كان هناك
دور كبير خلال هذه الفتره ليس فقط لاجلاء
الرعايه السعوديين ولكن لاجلاء اكثر من
جنسيه اخرى ان كان برا والان كوريا
بالفعل هنالك هنالك هنالك امتنان كبير من
قبل الرعايه الكوريين وحتى غير ذلك
الرعايه الخليجيين والعرب والاوروبيين بعد
ان تمت او نجحت عمليات اجلائهم الى مدينه
جده تحدثنا عن عمليات الاجلاء البحري او
حتى عمليات الاجلاء الجوي وهذه الطائره هي
الاول طائره اخلاء جوي تتم او تصل الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه هنا في مدينه
جده نتحدث كذلك انه كافه العمليات الاجلاء
مستمره في من الخرطوم او تحديدا من بورد
سودان الى القاعده البحريه او حتى الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه نتحدث انه
متوقع خلال الساعتين القادمه وصول السفينه
على متنها 196 الشخص من بينهم جميعهم
اجانب وصول قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
هل يعني هذه هي الرحله الاولى من المتوقع
سوف تكون هنالك
ذكرت سلطان انه ننتظر 196 من الرعايه
الاجانب ان يصلوا الى السعوديه في عمليه
اجلاء سعوديه هل يعني انه كافه السعوديين
قد تم اجلائهم بالفعل من السودان
تم اجراء كافه الرعايه السعوديين خلال
اليومين الماضي وهم عددهم 91 شخص وتبقى
فقط في الخرطوم السفير السعودي وبعض موظفي
البعثات البعث الدبلوماسيه السعوديه هناك
لكن فيما يتعلق بالرعايه المواطنين
وعائلتهم وصلوا جميعا الى الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه يوم خلال يوم امس وتحديدا
صباح يوم قبل قبل يومين من الان او 48
ساعه تحديدا يعني وصلوا الى قاتل الملك
فيصل وهم جميع
متمتعون بصحه وعافيه وسلامتكم وسلامتهم
وتم تسكين كافه الرعايه الاجانب في فنادق
في جده وهي عدده اربع فنادق حتى يتم انهاء
كافه اجراءاتهم ومن ذلك استعدادا لذهابهم
الى بلدانهم طيب ذكرت انه السفير السعودي
لا زال متواجد هناك مع بعض الموظفين نعلم
ان السفاره الامريكيه اغلقت ابوابها عدد
من السفارات ايضا اغلقت ابوابها طبيعه عمل
السفاره السعوديه ام ان التواجد السعودي
هو انساني بحث الان في اطار المساعده في
عمليات الاجلاء وربما الدفع نحو نوع من
الحل اذا مصحه تعبير او تقريب وجهات النظر
بين الرجلين
بطبيعه الحال وجود السفير السعودي في
الخرطوم هو موجود مهم جدا على كافه
الاصعده اذا تحدثنا على الصعيد المهم جدا
وهو عمليات الاجلاء نعلم انه كثير من
السفارات الاجنبيه طلبت من الحكومه
السعوديه او من السفر السعوديه في الخرطوم
ان تقوم بعمليات اجلائهم الى مدينه جده
بحرا او حتى جول تمت الموافقه على بعض
الطلبات وكما ذكرنا وصل 157 شخص 91 ونحن
الان بانتظار 196 من الرعايه الاجانب
الذين كانوا في السودان وتم اجلائهم وسيتم
اجلائهم باذن الله
بمساعده المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده سلطان
السلمي مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المعلومات
وفي مدينه بورتسودان تستمر عمليه الاجلاء
ايضا تشهد المدينه حراك كبير من البعتات
الدبلوماسيه وايضا الرعايه العديد من
الدول الغربيه تمهيدا لاجلائهم
طبعا بالاضافه الى اجلاء 72 موظفا اماميا
من دارفور الى تشاد مؤكدا على بقاء الامم
المتحده في السودان ودعمها للشعب السوداني
بكافه الوسائل الممكنه حتى حل الازمه
[موسيقى]
تحركنا من منطقه الخرطوم الى منطقه على
بعد حوالي 1200 1300 كرت كيلو صعب
وحول الجهود الاقليميه لانهاء الازمه
الراهنه في السودان بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع نظيره
الياباني يوشيماسا هياشي وقفه تصعيد
العسكري في السودان وانهاء العنف وتوفير
الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين وتهدئه التوترات
المتصاعده في عدد من المواقع الحيويه داخل
البلاد
هذا ولم تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بين
طرفي النزاع في السودان في اخرها اتهام
وجهته قوات الدعم السريع للجيش بتنفيذ
غاره جويه على احياء سكنيه متفرقه من
العاصمه الخرطوم اليوم مؤكده انها استهدفت
المدنيين وبشكل مباشر في حي الدوحه بام
درمان ومنطقه الكلاكله بجنوب الخرطوم
وقالت في بيان لها انها تعمل على تقديم
الخدمات الاساسيه وفتح ممرات انسانيه في
هذه المرحله الصعبه التي تشهدها البلاد
الى جانب انشغالها باجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ورعاي الدول الاجنبيه
هذا واظهرت مقاطع فيديو حصريه لقناه
العربيه حجم الدمار والاضرار التي خلفها
القصف على منطقه الكلاكله الواقعه جنوب
الخرطوم دعونا نتابع
[تصفيق]
الو
في بيت وقع الان
شايف الغبار ده
هذا هو اظهرت الصور تحركات لقوات الدعم
السريع وهي تقوم بتمشيط عدد من الاحياء
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم نتابع
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اعلن الجيش السوداني استقرار
الموقف في العمليات الجيش الشرى في بيينه
الى توسيع نطاق تامين منطقه الخرطوم لتجنب
الحاق اضرار بالمناطق السكنيه فيما جدد
دعوته لعناصر الدعم السريع بالاستسلام
بيان الجيش التهمه قوات الدعم السريع
باستخدام المدنيين كدروع بشريه البيان اكد
ان الاتصالات ما زالت مستمره مع الدول
الاجنبيه الراغبه في اجلاء الدبلوماسيه
السودان
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
حول الاوضاع الطبيه اعلنت نقابه اطباء
السودان عن التعرض مناطق متفرقه بالخرطوم
الى قصف باسلحه ثقيله كما اكدت مقتل عدد
من المدنيين في منطقه الكلاكده ووصول عدد
القتلى الى
273 مدنيا واصابه
1579 حتى هذه اللحظه وذكرت النقابه بان
عدد القتلى الحقيقي غير معروف لتعذر وصول
جثثهم الى المستشفيات
[موسيقى]
على كل المزيد معنا في الاستوديو عثمان
بوانين وهو رئيس تحالف قوه الخلاص الوطني
السوداني اهلا بك استاذي بدايه كوننا
استمعنا الى جزء من جلسه مجلس الامن هل
تعولون على مجلس الامن ما الذي يمكن ان
يقدم بهذا الاطار
بالحقيقه في البدن نحن نشكر القناه اللي
استضافتكم
ونقدم يعني عبركم
تحياتنا للشعب السوداني الصابر الصامت وان
شاء الله يعني السودان سوف يعود يعني كما
كان في البدء يعني
بالحقيقه هو مجلس الامن الان يعني له يعني
عنده الان يعني مداولات حول الوضع الراهي
في السودان ولكن نحن الان نعول على الجبهه
الداخليه قبل الجبهه الخارجيه وهنالك الان
مبادره طرحت من الاتحاد الافريقي وان شاء
الله يعني هذه المبادره سوف ترى النور وهي
مقبوله لدى كل القوى السياسيه
المبادره والى اي حد
هي قادره عن ان تفرض ربما رؤيتها على
الاطراف الان وخاصه انه استمعنا انه كل
رجل متمسك بموقفه هو بالحقيقه هذه
المبادره الان بيقود السيد
رئيس جزر القمر باعتباره انه هو رئيس
الدوره الحاليه للاتحاد الافريقي والان في
تواصل هو مع الطرفين يعني يتواصل معهم
مباشره وجد منهم الضوء الاخضر وفي يعني
تفاصيل يتكلموا فيها والمفروض يعني تطرح
يمكن يعني اليوم او غدا يعني مباشره
نعرف التف او لا نعرف لا لا نعرف نعم
بالحقيقه نحن يعني بنرى انه الاتحاد
الافريقي هو مقبول ضد الطرفين لانه منذ
البدء يعني الاتحاد الافريقي كان جزء من
المشكله وكان جزء يعني من حل المشكله
البدائيه من ايام الثوره فبالتالي وايضا
هو يعني مقبول لدى كل الاطراف في السودان
ونحن نريد ان يكون مقبول فكره ان ينجح جهه
اخرى لانه ذكرت انه كان خلال كل هذه
الفتره موجود ولكن يبدو ان كل المبادرات
وكل المحاولات من قبله
لكي ينتقل السودان الى
نظام مدني لم ينجح نعم هو بالحقيقه يمكن
الوضع الحاصل انه كان في تدخلات اجنبيه
كثيره جدا جدا وايضا هنالك كانت يعني في
عده مبادرات مطروحه على الساحه ولكن الان
يعني المرحله الحاليه يعني تتطلب انه
القناه تكون واحده او المنصه للمبادرات
كلها تصب يعني في منصه واحده ثم بعد ذلك
يعني تقدم الى الجهات المختلفه
سؤال الطرفين
عن الطرفين ان يرضيا الاب باي مبادره بعد
كل ما حدث واذا كان احد مسيطره على الارض
الان ميدانيا لماذا سيقبل هو اي اي نزاح
في العالم يعني بيعود الى مائده المفاوضات
دايما يعني يعني النزاعات هي يعني ما
بتفرض نفسها يعني يعني بالنسبه للواقع على
الارض وكذا ولكن يعني نرى الان الطرفين هم
صراعا حول السلطه فبالتالي الان هنالك
يعني قوه يعني يعني موجوده وهذه القوه
يعني في نظر الكثيرين وفي نظر يعني القوات
المسلحه السودانيه هي جزء من القوات
السودانيه وهي التي تمردت على السلطه
الرئيسيه في البلاد فبالتالي يعني وجب
حسناء عسكريا كجانب عسكري عن هذا ولكن نحن
نتكلم كجانب سياسي لابد ان تعود الدوله
الى دوله مدنيه عبر مائده المفاوضات هذا
ما يريده الجميع اليوم استمعنا الى
تصريحات لمستشار حميدتي يقول فيها سنصل
الى ما نريد اما بالحل العسكري او
بالتفاوض هل كلمه التفاوض هنا ربما تصب به
اطار المبادره الموجوده هل هناك تلمست نوع
من تغيير في المواقف او لا الان طبعا هم
في لحظه حرب اي طرف الان يحب يعني يحقق
مكاسب يعني اكثر بالنسبه له بالتصريحات
بخلافه ولكن
الوسطاء دائما هم اللي بيغيروا الوضع
الحاصل سواء على الارض او الوضع الميدان
والوضع السياسي عبر مائده المفاوضات ولكن
نحن نرى انه هذه المساله لابد ان تحل عبر
مائده المفاوضات
وتحل عبر منصه الحريه والتغيير الاولى
التي توافق على الشعب اللي هي الوثيقه
الدستوريه الاولى التوافق عليها الشعب
السوداني في عام 2019
الحل هل تراه بوجود الرجلين ايضا وعودتهم
للسلطه بغض النظر عن طبيعه الحكم اللي راح
يكون خلال هذه الفتره الانتقاليه الان
طبعا المرحله لانه الوحده الان يعني نحن
يعني لسنا الان في مرحله عشان نغيم انه
منا يعني يكون موجود ماده المفاوضات
والقوه السياسيه هي التي يعني ستقرر اذا
الناس مثلا يعني
ثوره المفاوضات هنالك يمكن حديث اخر يعني
في كل وقت نكون المدني هل له كلمه الان
باعتقادك المكون المدني الان يعني المكون
المدني مع الدوله هو الان المكون المدني
يمكن منقسم وهو جزء اصلا سبب المشكله
الاساسيه اللي كانت تمت يعني اللي هو
مكونه لاطار هي السبب في هذه الزعزعه حصلت
ولكن المكون الان مع الثوره والجزء
الاساسي هو من الحريه والتغيير الان هو مع
يعني مع يعني مع الوطن ويريد له الاستقرار
ويريد
يكون هناك توحد الان على كلنا عثمان
بوانين رئيس تحالف قوه الخلاص الوطني
السوداني شكرا جزيلا لك
وبهذا مشاهدينا وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
التغطيه ولكن اترككم الان مع هذا اللقاء
الذي اجراه واجرته العربيه مع مجلس
السياده الانتقالي في السودان رئيس المجلس
السيادي الانتقالي في السودان عبد الفتاح
البرهان ولكن التغطيه تستمر ايضا على راس
الساعه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات